Okay. Now we need to calculate the singular
values and that's just eigen.
If you remember how we find the
eigenvalues of The Matrix.
First we use the determinant function.
And then we get the characteristic polynomial. Let
me pull up it previous tutorials just to refresh your memory.
Okay. So for step three, there's a sequence of steps where we're
just gonna since we've already looked at that we're gonna skip right to
the value, but let me refresh your memory.
Here's how you calculate the eigen values of
Matrix. So let's say this is our Matrix.
We take the identity Matrix.
You know, that's just one across diagonal multiplied by
Lambda. This is just this is the
the thing that is meant to be determined.
This is the indeterminate and we we want to determine what the values
of Lambda are. So we multiply the scalar value by this identity
Matrix we get lambdo.
across diagonal
then we take the difference of Matrix a minus this
new Matrix.
And I give this characteristic polynomial and then we solve for
Lambda we get two roots.
We we put access for our eigenvector.
And then we solve for the roots.
And these will be and these will be the values for our eigen
back here.
Yeah, so this Matrix.
Is that Matrix after we plug
in one of these eigenvalues?
So for this Matrix we chose one so you
plug in one inside as we plug in one
for Lambda.
And this Matrix will be changed that Matrix.
So we'll get the eigenvector.
When we solve this system.
Okay, so I'm going to skip this whole step.
And just give you the the eigenvalues.
these two matrices
a transpose times a
a times a transpose the eigenvalues for these two.
I am going to return.
to
Collab, this is Step. Number one.
This is the number one.
step number two was this
Okay, step number three.
the eigenvalues so I'm going to
denote this as
a t a
and this one aat
run that again.
this
now if you want to calculate the eigenvalues there is
an attribute or I should see object in numpy
called linear algebra. So I'm going to go NP the
linear algebra and I valves I
can values.
So let's extract the eigenvalues for the first Matrix.
This will give us 50 and 200.
I do the same for the other one.
Yeah, so step three is eigenvalues for both matrices. I'm
going to print.
this one
and I'm going to print this one.
And so the eigenvalues are 50 and 200.
But what we do is we take the square root of these.
So the square root of 200.
The square root of 200 is what 200?
Time out the power 2.5.
That's 14.4.
Just like we have here.
14.4
And the square root of 50.
would be
7.07 Okay, so we've
we have found.
The Matrix
S
The Matrix contain the singular value so the square root of
these values are the singular value
Which I will denote a sigma so Sigma sub
1 will be.
Let's just the first one.
at zero
But then I need to take the square roots. I have to import the
mat.
the math Library so important math
And then I'm going to go math.
That sqrt.
And the same thing for Sigma.
I'm going to print these.
Sigma 1
okay.
and this would be seven.
points
Okay.
so
we get this Matrix.
this is actually step 4 right step three is just
Sigma 1 and sigma 2 so Sigma
one we said was equal to 200.
Sigma
2 was equal to 50.
then
Or number four. We just take square root of those Sigma. So let
me just add another Matrix.